Pokemon go is not out in Canada yet so
what we're doing right now is super
black market later outlaws know like we
could end up in Nintendo jail bro and
you don't want to end up there because
you don't wanna take care play mario
party you don't you don't want to see
you don't want to see Bowser in the
shower that's all I'm gonna say before
you got the Pokemon every need this is
the box chill chill chill
it's ridiculous that it's not available
in canada now right because we would be
playing like even if you have to pay we
would pay but since it's not available
in canada at all and we have to wait and
just listen to a merit I like Americans
talk about it it's like Game of Thrones
like having to wait like a year for to
watch the season when they already
watched it so I think the only right
thing to do would be show you guys and
Canada how to unlock Pokemon go and I
assume other countries as well right
yeah awesome probably first you gotta go
on your settings and security and then
you have to allow unknown sources allow
installation of abs from sources other
than google play store all right now and
now I'll argue now you just gotta go on
the internet go into the URL and type in
apk mirror com no space well kind of use
the magical google in this one now
scroll down for pokemon go there it is
Pokemon go gotta click the download
button right there and then guys it'll
start downloading just gotta be patient
and then once it downloads you just got
to open it up let it download you open
the app which will finds through other
apps and you can play and I'm a human
male you take the character you get to
pick a few stuff like skin tone like
between three different pants with
different stripes on them not a wide
variety of choices but so just enough to
be a little bit a winner yeah I guess
you can get blue hair what's an iMac and
I get so how do we do this now great
walk around and so apparently you got a
tap on the Pokemon you want okay so goes
and got Charmander Charmander so I'm
gonna get squirtle because
I'm the best he's on the stairs guys so
I'm just down the stairs oh I got
squirrel on my stairs Oh got him got him
cause I sure don't be so sure what's
going on I don't know to the
anticipation like release the music
still going right guys I just want to
say that I've always said that it was
Pokemon in my house and no one believed
me I was like you're crazy man there's
no pokemon on your staircase well who's
crazy now mr. therapist who's crazy now
we decided instead of walking to just
drive to our first polka spot so we'll
see how that goes
it is like 35 degrees right now so we're
we gotta go on we gonna move apparently
there's a Pikachu nearby and now crap as
well Evie just showing up to but they're
all three steps away so which you know
could be anywhere but we'll see if it
gets closer as we drive for is the polka
spot
yeah but like I didn't get a zoo bad
supposed to be easy to capture I don't
know what them oh man that's the thing i
like moment oh by the way guys goes and
wasted like 85 pokeballs kazoo bet so so
he's off talk about battery charge here
at spoke the center so I'll get back to
you so did you open it flip it swipe it
and now you click the pokeballs
there we go
alright that's our first visit to a
polka center we didn't get any Pokemon
but we got three poke balls which like I
wish it was more because I wasted like
70 on a pidgeot and like for Tiana zubat
but whatever still doing gather by the
MTN by the way
alright guys so we just we just got
busted by the cops or playing pokemon
going Canada told you guys it's black
market outlaw stuff that was a close one
it was very close and I'll we're just
gonna we're gonna keep going and
hopefully we can avoid those cops again
guys